rise a perfect example of the unintended
consequences in giving all of your
rights over to the government this is
someone who has no concept of the
parameters of government if it may help
people and it won't let's assume that it
may make people healthier it's not your
job to ensure that people don't over and
by mr. pip so let's talk about Mike
Bloomberg again I wanna know what you
guys think is it you see the same kind
of billionaires Donald Trump why do
people see Donald Trump as a billionaire
who's of the people a little more in
touch and Mike Bloomberg is someone who
is completely totally out of touch I
think it's because of exactly the kind
of behavior that we've seen from
Bloomberg the last two weeks this was
his first debate performance last night
and it was universally panned as a
disaster as a matter of fact for people
who missed it the the whole debate was a
disaster he sounds like the lily tomlin
operator what's the absorption rate do
ethiopian genetics affected I have no
idea are you an ultra-rapid metabolizer
the point is I get that you want to die
Lester so did I so let's look at all the
reasons that Mike Bloomberg is a piece
of
[Music]
alright I'm gonna bring in my half a
pill because he's uncomfortable and I'm
gonna bring you in more against your
will completely you're so quiet today
reason number five is uh I think a lot
of people remember this that the soda
ban a lot of people know big gulps maybe
didn't understand how unpopular this was
in New York City of all places so in
2012 Bloomberg actually banned sodas
over 16 ounces in all of New York City I
think that you're not gonna see a lot of
pushback here at all I think everybody
crushed Wow we should do it he may not
have expected to hold another press
conference later that same day you've
expended so much personal political
capital on this do you see everybody
else do what's right to save lives
obesity it's just no question about it
he was he banned sodas and then of
course represented the ban was promptly
shut down by a New York Supreme Court
judge though I will say to be fair many
people believe he was bought and paid
off by big quick trip so there's that
yeah my god rise a perfect example of
the unintended consequences in giving
all of your rights over the government
you clear everything to be a
constitutional right like they do in in
Germany I don't think they have the same
constitutional you but they declare
internet or I don't think they do either
so if you declare the right goods and
services that right can be taken away
this is someone who has no concept of
the parameters of government even if it
may help people and it won't let's
assume that it may make people healthier
it's not your job to ensure that people
don't over and by mr. pip boo who drinks
mister yeah Mr taco bell's also by the
way I think you tried to ban Taco Bell
different personal reasons we can't get
into there's an NDA here so reason
number four as to why such a piece of
excrement um the whole I don't remember
the homeless food ban I didn't hear
about yeah I don't know so he actually
banned food donations to the homeless
because the city couldn't quote assess
their salt fat in fiber content yeah so
no food at all yeah
that's better and by the way that
eliminates pretty much everything in a
can drive oh my god right you're not
you're not buying prime organic rib eye
let me tell us this in the bag never a
Girl Scout cookies no you're putting in
the Jolly Green Giant green beans if
anything now you just be doing it to
spite Bloomberg yeah it's not like they
were trying to donate the bottom of the
muffin I mean who would do that
I I would just give a little time push
beans just to piss you off
they're smelly a city as America to note
because he wants to be President of the
United States and I think it's important
to know that this is someone who
probably won't be president of let's be
honest he won't be president okay yeah
if it's Bloomberg and Hillary Clinton
2020 let's just call it from 2020 what
up on the scoreboard let's be honest
here but he wants to push these diet
regulations at the absolute highest
levels of government wind up with a lot
less sodium in the food so eat is really
crucial to our health and our business
governments at all levels must make
healthy solutions the default social
option for the things that we run
because of all sorts of safety reasons
we just have a policy of my
understanding of not taking donations
right okay we get it
no one should be allowed salty fatty
food ever except
Oh
[Laughter]
you know it's a little bit gangster
maybe enjoy my streets good for you of a
burg you affected elitist reason number
three this is a good example and this is
also I would like him to run because
talk about the coastal Elise right this
is someone who hasn't he's so out of
touch with Middle America
he doesn't realize that this will come
back to bite him people won't talk about
the NDA's and the sexual harassment the
truth is that Donald Trump has shown you
can turn that into a positive if you
have to right I said they let you fish
hook of their own volition folks so he
did say this though far worse than the
NDA's or sexual that farmers are
effectively idiots so he claimed in this
I think we have its clip right that
anyone could be taught to anyone anyone
could farm but that tech jobs take quote
real gray matter here you go
and we could teach processes I could
teach anybody even people in this rooms
don't no offense intended to be a farmer
you it's a processor you dig a hole you
put a seed in you put dirt on top add
water up comes the coin Wow that's all
the goods Wow that's because you did
farming I knew I'd seen him somewhere
Bloomberg good for him process C Singh
yeah yeah if I ever say anything that
stupid please comedian lee come in it
not this show we'll do it afterwards
long list but speaking like I get it I
said Mike as opposed to Nike because of
the french-canadian
solace sounds like solace and that's
just because I'm a stupid cane it's a
silly country but process see he shows
you don't understand that word right you
don't know what that what that word is
supposed to mean you don't know what I
supposed to mean
it's making of things that people
understand please do hit the
notification bell if you're watching on
YouTube hit all notifications because
otherwise you don't get them at all I
guess anymore and subscriptions don't
mean a lot there's also crowd or bits
chin does it go and watch some exclusive
content of course mug club is what keep
the doors open because we're not
monetized but
spoiler alert we all know that if you've
read a news article in the last year
ever reason number two we have two more
reasons to get you then we have mayor
Rudolph Giuliani um he I don't know the
way to any other way to frames this but
um he wants old he wants old cancer
patients to die yeah I think so let me
explain that the context of this I'm not
this isn't actually hyperbole at all he
wants to expand government-run health
care course they all do and he's praised
socialized medicine in Europe we know
that but he has some very interesting
ideas I don't think is any different
than the people who are pushing for
Medicare for all they just don't usually
come out and say it this way as to how
they might cut some health care costs
and we've got a say here and say which
things we're gonna do longer since when
I show up
with prostate cancer 95 years old we
should say go and enjoy have a nice to
leave a long lines no cure
what right oh my gosh you think he
doesn't even consider the fact that
you're not the one who's supposed to
decide
I get that logically people are saying
someone's 95 they probably don't have
long to live
here's the thing it doesn't matter if
they want to pay for health care
Bloomberg doesn't get to choose whether
they live or die and by the way this is
what happens in socialized health care
countries a lot of us don't know this
that is very common later in the meeting
he went on to describe how socialized
healthcare was superior to ours by the
way and he said if you look in Europe we
spent here about seven thousand odd
dollars per person per year on health
care in Europe it's about three thousand
three hundred less than half and their
life expectancy is two to three years
greater here's the thing a lot of you
wonder it's a common stat people say
life expectancy is not related to health
care we have test holiday that changes
the average by like three years yeah
just right oh nice shoes to be obese
Peter can choose to be very fit a good
example that is Texas right yeah I think
Houston is the fattest city I think in
the country no yeah that's what I
believe and depending where you go like
obviously there's a higher concentration
of them at the last Kmart left yeah and
if they're shooting around commercial
less than sixty I think Dallas so I'm
not mistaken it was rated one of the
city with the most fit people because
you have a lot of athletes here the
thing if you are in Texas you can eat
incredibly healthfully at a very low
price or you can eat nothing but crap
that's a byproduct of freedom that's
also the byproduct of being able to pay
for your own health care you get to
choose when you no longer pay for health
care or when your life is no longer
worth living Bloomberg it doesn't even
occur to him because they believe that
all of the rights belong to them and
keep in mind by the way this is very
common this is it's not even a
controversial issue in Europe even to
the extremes of death panels many people
got really mad when we talked about
death panels
remember the cases of I think was
Charlie guard Alfie Evans yeah they're
both children severe health problems who
wanted to try alternative treatments the
UK government decided that it was time
for them to die and those are extreme
examples let's go to the rule rather
than the exception rash
surgery's extremely common in places
like the UK elderly blind patients
they're currently forced to wait a year
and a half for simple cataract surgery
had a girlfriend by the way in high
school whose dad was German actually
fought for Hitler
he refused to get cataract removed
because the doctor was Jewish true so
what have you ever actually heard Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren say we would
have better care they say oh it might be
cheaper they say it'll be less calm
it'll be less complicated you won't have
to deal with insurance companies despite
the fact that the overwhelming majority
of Americans actually wants you to keep
their insurance plans they always argue
it's the right thing to do not that it's
going to be better quality right because
dealing with the government has proven
easier than dealing with insurance
companies right well that's not at all
like Medicare you know our people like
Medicare and Medicaid but you're dealing
with very very small percentage of
people you expand it it gets more
difficult I know you want socialized
health care a lot of you I'm not a fan
reason number one that Michael Bloomberg
is in fact a piece of and I think this
is the obvious one he's really he's just
a billionaire who's literally attempting
to buy an election right notice that
here's something that here's some
numbers that a lot of people don't
necessarily know have you noticed the
charities that have an endorsing
Bloomberg coincidentally he gave them
millions Wow millions of dollars what
about the Democrats surprisingly
endorsing Bloomberg surely they must
believe in his ideas they like the Liza
Minnelli tracksuit that he wears but it
also doesn't hurt the loom Berg that the
three House Democrats supporting and
received 8.9 million dollars from him in
not 2018 midterms not connected at all
no by the way that that law works like a
charm doesn't it with campaign donation
cats jerk did hard time Craig you think
giving five grand to a friend is running
a Senate seat it didn't even win yeah
he's walking around an ankle bracelet
having to blow and his niece on to make
sure that he can go down the store to
get a gallon of milk let's give an eight
point nine million dollars to people
endorsing him in a national platform and
have you seen it folks there's another
thing the folks endorsing Bloomberg on
social media hey I take that personally
I will spend that under 250 dollars
wisely yes
the thousand to a hundred thousand
followers on Twitter or Instagram a
hundred and fifty dollars for an
endorsement which begs the question how
much for a million or five million
YouTube subscribers who cash out at this
is I think the big problem to have with
Bloomberg I think is it's most
emblematic because it's just sort of
bumbling Bernie Sanders proactively
blatant just what and disregard for the
Constitution or parameters of
appropriate limited government
I don't think Bloomberg has any
understanding because he's so wealthy
he's such an elitist he's surrounded by
yes men he has been for so long he'd
understand that he's not a king that he
shouldn't be in charge of these issues
and by the way let's compare this to
president Donald Trump when people say
well he's a billionaire so he's a
dictator but right really by lower taxes
and deregulation and allowing that more
people to have guns like allowing more
businesses to open up fewer stringent
regulations you can say whatever you
want but that's not exactly the the
actions of an autocratic dictator
Bloomberg thinks he can control what you
drink and you want to put this man in
the office I'm saying that of course
facetiously I know that none of you want
to put of an office anywhere at any
point and these are and we have to get
to Giuliani a little bit these are the
unintended consequences of big
government it may sound good at this
point Medicare for all let's assume that
the quality of care would actually be
better or Medicaid for all or some kind
of a centralized public option let's
assume it would actually be better it
doesn't matter because long-term you
lose your choice and they can decide
what health care is taken away friend
maybe long term people not drinking big
gulps I think we would all agree
lots of sugary sodas not good for you
but if you think hey that will be better
for me so let's have the government step
in it's their job to to keep us safe
it's their job to ensure health guess
what it's their job to take away
whatever they want these are the people
who told us that saturated fat and that
egg yolks were bad that tallow was bad
for McDonald's fries so they started
cooking them with hydrogenated vegetable
oil now that I'm sorry we were wrong
about that sorry to everyone who has
elevated LDL and cancer we were mistaken
but the vegan activists and the USDA
kind of screwed the pooch on this one by
the way you can eat eggs now you I am so
of being told that I cannot eat eggs or
bacon and now now it's a good thing yeah
and then you have people go so far now
they're the carnivore diet now the USDA
is going the other way
we don't know what is the food pyramid
can anyone tell me what the appropriate
food pyramid is whatever Mike Bloomberg
says I believe the opposite let's just
go with that whenever you allow the
government to step into the realm of no
longer rights what are rights they're
enshrined in the Constitution freedom of
speech freedom of self-preservation
freedom from unwarranted search and
seizure but goods and services like
drinks like health care like yeah even
drinking water being filtered and piped
to your tap when you allow the
government to have complete control over
goods and services they can take them
away and you end up with 12 ounce soft
drinks which we all know we're not
satisfying and some might argue more
importantly death panels this has been
this week's what a piece
[Music]
mm-hmm you know what's in here it's just
water that's why they call it acting but
it actually smells garlicky there's
something wrong with the water I think
it's going through the ice maker we
don't have we don't have the baking soda
in the fridge if you liked this video
subscribe hit notifications or just
check back every single day because we
upload a new video every single day this
is actually taken from the full show a
full hour show the way upload every
single Thursday click that right now go
watch the entire show if you don't want
to you don't you don't have to but if
you if you stop by you know just don't
bother me I'm gonna enjoy my garlic
water